Hey traders, this is Mike here and in
this video I'm going to talk about the
only entry model you'll ever need, which
is order flow exhaustion and I want to
take you through some of the settings
just to show you on Order Flow Trader
how to set it up. You know, if you don't
have Order Flow Trader software, if
you're using
a a normal footprint, you know, you're
not going to have this ability. That's
why, you know, I created the Order Flow
Trader software so I can see specific
nuances in the order flow such as order
flow exhaustion. So, what am I using
right here? This is my exhaustion print.
You can see it right here.
Okay.
It's uh enabled, right? It's got the
little check mark. I use the swing
filter and you got it set at 10. So, you
know, you can choose what you want to
set it at. You know, if you're using a
thinner market, you know, I'm showing
you guys on E-minis. Um you know, say
you're trading in Euro currencies,
um maybe you want to use five. If you're
trading in a thinner market uh that has
a bit more volatility such as crude,
maybe you want to
uh use a lower number such as three. And
also
the look the swing filter, right? I have
the swing filter set at 25. So, I'm
really capturing
um nice swing highs and swing lows.
Also, if it came in at the high of the
day or the low of the day, it would also
uh trigger. So, with those settings,
let's just uh take a look at what
happened today.
So, again, you know, today is the uh
21st of May and you know, it started out
kind of a quiet uh
quiet morning, you know, we're just sort
of
>> [sighs and gasps]
>> putting a little bit of rally, just
hanging around uh unchanged for most of
the morning or hanging around rather
where we opened at and then about uh
10:00, you got a nice exhaustion print
right here, right? The Order Flow Trader
uh puts this little down triangle. If
it's bearish, it would put a blue up
triangle if it was bullish and I like to
draw the zone out until tested and you
can see often times, right, the market
trades right back up towards that level
as well. Um I like to use the until
tested to draw out the zone, so it's
very visual. And
we have our exhaustion print coming in
on this red candle, right? I look at how
the market was trading prior to that in
terms of delta on the swing high. We got
the negative delta minus 42.
But we have this nice little rally going
up. Just remember, right? You have an
exhaustion print. So, you want to have
some sort of move that took place. And
we rallied from about 7415 up to about
7430. So, you know, it was a 15-point
move. So, you know, you want to be
looking for a potential reversal anyway.
And, you know, the deltas, you know, on
this move up were were positive, which
is what you're expecting to see. But
it's sort of as we right before we get
this pop up with this bar here with the
strong delta of 324. You know, the delta
was actually getting a little bit
weaker. It was 356, 200, 124, minus 19
on this red bar. Had that one last burst
of buying right here. Big positive delta
of 324. Big bar up, but it didn't
sustain it, right? It just traded up a
little bit and then you got your
exhaustion print, right? You got your
signs of exhaustion that, hey, you know
what? This move up is probably over.
Then in the next bar we get
confirmation. We trade below the low of
the signal bar, the bar with the
exhaustion print. That's your sign to
get short. Um, you know, you're going to
place your stop up above that high of
the signal bar around 7430,
right? So, you know, you're getting
short somewhere around 74 26. So, this
is your risk right here.
Okay? And, you know, over the next few
minutes it does trade back inside this
bar. So, it is nowhere near your stop,
right? It's still about two points off
our stop, but it is uh you are taking a
little bit of heat for a few minutes
before the market drops from your entry
around 74
uh 25 and a half all the way down to
7410. We even make a new swing low. So,
you know, we're looking you know, you're
risking
you know, about four points to get what?
You know, 7410 is right here, but you
know, we'll call it 7412, right? This is
Right? This is where you'd be getting
short and there's your stop, right? So,
this is your risk, but this is
what you able to get out of the trade.
This whole move right here before it
starts going sideways right around 7412.
You got a full 1 2 3 4 minutes to get
out at 7412
considering you're getting short at 74,
you know, 25 25 and a half.
Okay?
That was the first one.
Let's take a look here for anything else
later today.
I think there was a couple more here. We
got this little one here at this swing
low, okay?
>> [snorts]
>> But I want to show you this cuz this is
interesting, right? So, we got our nice
move down, okay? We're coming down, you
got the negative deltas minus 65 minus
63 positive delta 136, okay? Minus 515,
then you get down here on the swing low
minus 48. It's a green candle. You see
the exhaustion print of three. Here's
your little signal here, your up arrow.
Next bar starts trading higher, okay?
Higher than the high of the signal bar,
which is what we like to see. Then it
goes sideways for the next 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 minutes.
It's just a little bit in the money.
But most of the time it's kind of
against you. Yeah, you're pushing 10
minutes, which
you know, when when you're a position
and you're not really getting paid, it's
probably not going to really work out,
okay? I mean, that's just the reality of
it. You know, you you you have your
signal, right? You have your catalyst of
the reason for getting long, but the
market just doesn't have any strength to
it, okay?
And you know, like I said, you know, the
zone is is visual and you can see it
literally came right back to that same
price level where it trades four lots,
and then it works its way back up. But,
you know, realistically, after you're in
this trade for about 10 minutes, and you
know, you're not
Basically, you're not getting paid, you
know, being able to scratch the trade, I
think is is the right decision. You
know, maybe you take, you know, a
one-point loss or something like that,
but
you know, it it's not a trade that you
really want to hold. You know, you
you're not going to
the market's not going to go, you know,
you're not going to get your bullish
signal. You get long, and then it just
spends all this time underwater.
A little bit, you know, it's not going
It's hasn't stopped you out yet, and
then it sort of pops up, and then it
just sort of goes sideways, and then it
sort of comes back down to your entry.
You got to understand when to get out.
And then it comes down, doesn't quite
stop you out, makes another run.
This is your If you didn't get out
somewhere in here, or up here, or over
here,
this is a gift getting out here.
Anywhere in here is a gift to get out
at, okay? Don't don't look a gift horse
in the mouth in the mouth. Don't expect
the market to go sideways, up a little
bit, down one tick off your stop, and
then back up, and then make the move,
right? You got to cut it in here if you
haven't already. Maybe you take a small
loss in here, you know, if you didn't
take a small profit in here, or you
didn't scratch the trade in there. You
had plenty of opportunity, rather than
let it come down here much later and
stop you out. Me, I like to give the
trade about 10 minutes. If it's not
working out, just just get out of the
trade, you know, take lick your wounds,
so to speak. You know, you take the loss
if you have to,
rather than expecting something else to
happen. Now, there was a couple here,
okay? And and and I want to explain
these two here,
because one you would have taken, one
you shouldn't take. Here's first one.
Here's the second one, okay? The first
one trades four contracts, second time
it trades 10 contracts at this new high.
You know, you got your exhaustion print
for at this new high. You got a stack
selling a balance. That's nice. Got a
nice strong negative delta.
Um, you know, on working your way up,
it's got the positive deltas. There's
one negative delta in here, minus 313.
Okay.
You know,
maybe you want to get short.
There There's There's nothing that says
you can't really get short. But, this
bar here
tells you you're not getting short. And
what I mean by that is we don't trade
below the low
of the signal bar, the bar with the
exhaustion print. So, there's no trade.
There is no reason to be taking that
trade. Let the market take you in. If
this is true exhaustion, this next bar
is not going to trade inside. It's going
to start trading down.
And if it can't even do that, that's not
a trade that you're looking to do. And
for me, if it doesn't happen within one
bar or two bars,
definitely not a trade I'm looking to
take. Okay? But, if, you know, you're
one of these guys that say, "I got my
exhaustion print. I got to get short."
You have your stop up here, you're going
to get stopped out. But, really,
you let the market take you in. It just
It
you know,
what happened up here could just be
profit taking. Remember, right at our
highs of the day. You know, maybe some
traders are taking profits up here. But,
this next one up here, this is
much better to take. Why?
Okay, obviously you got your exhaustion
print of 10.
You know, you got your same imbalances
just like here. You got four. You got
your selling imbalances.
Um, this one's got a big strong negative
delta, seven minus 727. Over here, you
had minus 545. The difference, the next
bar starts trading down. It takes you
into that trade, right?
It didn't go inside, you know, and trade
here and just sort of go sideways. What
you need is that follow-through order
flow. Other traders coming in, also
getting short. The market's not going to
sell off because you think it is. It's
going to sell off because other traders
are selling, right? They're
traders aren't sitting around saying,
"Hey, what is uh
you know, the trader in Iowa doing?
Is he selling? He sold three contracts.
Okay, let's all get short." No, you
know, the market Everyone else is
trading based off of their method of
trading, their analysis, right? And if
they don't think it's time to get short,
market ain't going to go down.
But, up here at this high,
right? Now you you've got,
you know, similar things. You got your
exhaustion print. You got your strong
negative delta.
You got your imbalances. But, not only
that, you have other traders also
getting short. How do I know? Because
traders are hitting this bid. They're
clearing out the bid. They're hitting
the next bid and the next bid and the
next bid. Okay, market pauses, comes
back up, same thing. Okay, and the
market sells off again from this area
where you
gotten short, call it 7481,
trades all the way down to, you know,
the 60s, right in here. All right, this
is 70 here. 71 would be 10 points.
What's your risk?
Stop up here at the high, 7487.
Again, you're you're short from around
81, so that's like six
points.
Goes from 81 down to 66.
That's uh 15 points, right? That's
definitely uh a nice trade.
Definitely more than one to one.
Okay? And eventually, it does go a
little bit lower, right? It it comes
down here.
Whoops.
So again, you know,
>> [snorts]
>> can't draw a line to save my life here.
Um
Okay, you know, you're short from there.
All right, it comes down,
you know, bounces up, comes back down
lower, down to 64.
Below 64, gets down to 63. So, you know,
anywhere in here, you realistically
could have got out, even up in here.
When it come back down here, if you're a
bit
have stronger balls, maybe you could
have got out down here. Okay? But
definitely
once the market, you know, you got to
understand, right? This is S&P's. If
S&P's have nice rotations of 10 points,
12 points,
14 points. You This is your rotation,
right? You should be looking to get out
after you have a rotation.
Okay, so you know, that's
three exhaustion prints, well
four, right? But this one here you
wouldn't have taken.
Um and just recently
right here off this swing low, got this
nice exhaustion print. Now, this one
sort of set up
interestingly. So, you got your
exhaustion print of two, but we were
coming down, right? We came down from
7474,
30-point move.
Or is that a 25-point move rather down
to 7440?
No, it's a 30-point move. I can't I
can't think right now.
Um you got your exhaustion print of two,
and it was coming down hot, right? I
mean, this bar is a big bar down, you
know, this is bar is over 10 points.
This bar is about 10 points as well,
eight points. Strong deltas. Look at
this selling here, minus 2,000 in this
bar,
minus 1594 in this bar, minus 400. So,
big burst of selling here, big burst of
selling here,
big burst of selling here. But it's
getting weaker, 2,114,
1,500, 400.
After that, trades a little bit lower
and just trades two contracts there
before the market reverses. This bar
even had negative delta of 267. You can
see it's just this little green body, so
it was a red candle here,
but buying came in, turned it back up,
made a new high in the bar. Um I'll say
new high, but in the bar it formed a new
high before closing down off the high.
So, it's just a little green candle
right here, but it left that exhaustion
print. Next bar
trades above the high of the bar of with
the exhaustion print, right? That's your
entry to get long in there. 74
What is that?
Call it 7444,
right in here.
Okay.
Does pull back.
Pulls back down towards 38, but your
stop is
right down here, right below the low of
the exhaustion print, right? It does get
close, doesn't
doesn't trade there. You got another
little exhaust Yeah, three down here,
okay, for what it's worth.
Markets, you know, 1 minute, 2 minutes,
3 minutes, it's still you're still
still against you.
Okay, it's not the end of the world cuz
it's only been 3 minutes, but more
importantly, what are you starting to
see? Positive delta 300. That's
encouraging, you know, 117, small red
candle of just by about two ticks.
And then the buying comes in 400, 286,
325, and this market starts working its
way back up to 60, right? And this is
your entry, right? This
7444,
43 and 3/4.
All right. And even worked its way up.
Right now, we've got this other
exhaustion print. It's about 2:00 in the
afternoon. I mean, it did get all the
way up to 66. I mean, this is a move
from 30, you know, from 44 all the way
up into the 60s. That is a
here, right? You just draw the line
here, right here.
From where you'd get long, goes all the
way up to where you got your exhaustion
print up here.
Right? Even if you just held it to your
next exhaustion print,
44, this is 64 in here. It's 20 points.
Okay? Now, you do have an exhaustion
print here as well
that just formed. Okay, which that's
nice.
Um
Next bar started trading down. So, you
know, you're getting short in here.
Okay?
Look how it trades right back up
here.
Here, you got another exhaustion print
of three here. So, you got four here.
Trades up there. It goes bid actually.
It's bid offered at your stops. Offered
at your stop. It doesn't trade there.
Why? Because there was exhaustion. I
know here traders aren't really
interested in trading above this level.
That's why you put your stop there.
Because if they trade above that level,
you don't want to be in a position.
All right? The the whole
reason for getting short is gone. Okay?
And again, it's just hanging around your
entry price. 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 mostly against you.
Just on the other side of this line.
Little bit for you.
You know, but again, you know, you're
you're 10 minutes into this trade here.
And it's been the majority of the time
against you.
It's your time just to take the loss.
Especially, you know, after you just had
a 20-point run.
Yeah, I would like, you know, to be
honest, how often do you see markets
make a 20-point run,
reverse, make it another 20-point run
down. It happens. But if you're banking
on that, we're getting a bit late in the
session right now. Um chances are it's
probably not going to happen. I mean, it
could.
You know, before
eventually it did sort of break out
through that level, right above right
above
your
stop price and and stop you out. So,
again, you know,
that's why I say you you also got to
think about the time you're in a trade.
If you're short from here,
right? And
you know, this is your
area that you're short from.
And you're just spending the next
10 minutes
doing nothing, going
mostly against you.
Not very much time in your favor down
here, cuz if you're below this line,
remember you're you're short. So, if
you're
in here, it's just not making that run.
Okay? Take your scratch the trade. Wait
for another trade to come in. You know,
right now we've got another exhaustion
print forming right here.
Okay?
We'll see,
but we haven't
You know, this is actually the same
level here. This this line um
You know, we'll see what happens with
this one.
I don't want to keep you guys on this
video, but you know, it's
It's interesting to see how this stuff
uh how these trades play out. Okay? So,
if you're getting short, it's got to
trade below this price level within the
next minute or two, two minutes. It's a
minute base chart, 60-second chart,
actually. So, 1-minute chart. Um if it's
going to trade below there, yeah, I'd
want to be short.
But again, you know, I it's at this time
and look what time it is. It's uh
It's 2:20, or sorry, 2:40 in the
afternoon.
Okay, there. So, there's your entry to
get short. You got some nice selling
imbalances coming in here.
Okay?
Again, this is my exhaustion print right
here.
Boom. Okay? Now, it's making the run
down.
Okay? What am I risking?
Well,
there.
So, this is I just draw these lines in
here. Okay? So, short from right here.
Stop is going to go up here.
So, around 68 is my stop level.
Short uh what is that? About 61.
Go call it 7461.
Okay?
I'm sorry, that's not 61, that's 63. I
can't
can't read, man.
Color right there 63.
Can't type.
Um
you know, it's already three points, so
63 up to 68 you're just risking five
points.
Right now it's in your favor
a little bit.
59 and a half
59 and a quarter.
You know, but again, it's getting a
little bit late in the session. We got
cash close coming up in about uh
less than 20 minutes. So
you know, you might get a run towards
the cash close. You know, our high for
the day is not that far off from here.
Um
let's see here. What's our high?
High's up here 86 and uh three quarters.
Okay.
Trying to keep my lines here.
Okay, so it's sort of coming back. But
again, you know, I
I'll tell I'll pull this up later in my
in my next video. I just don't want to
keep you guys on too long.
See how it plays. Again, you know, but I
know
where is my stop? Is my stop is right
here.
Okay, so you know, we're back up to
break even. At least this one's going
>> [sighs and gasps]
>> you know, here you got some imbalances,
buying imbalances.
Got a little bit of
a selling imbalance there.
Just sort of hanging right around. You
know, this was interesting because you
had a zero. Just sort of break down some
of this other order flow that you're
seeing.
You got a zero print here, which is poor
flow. I'm not surprised to see it sort
of come back up here and fill that. Here
you got a one as well, also poor flow.
So we came back into these two areas.
Okay.
So,
just see how it uh how it develops.
Again, you know, if if you want to check
it out
yourself on on your own chart, uh pull
up about 20 minutes right before the
cash closes today on on uh Thursday, the
21st,
and see how it ends up. But again, you
know, I
But
at least it's in the favor. It's it's in
the money a bit.
And again, you know, you're short from
somewhere over here. Starting to work
its way back down.
Obviously, I'd want to start
coming in a bit lower. I mean, we got
the negative delta 339 minus 328 minus
88. You know, here right now we're
looking at minus 60 minus 50.
Okay.
But we're getting late in the day.
There is movements going into the cash
close.
But the same time, you know, how much
movement can you get at the same cuz for
me
I'll give this trade 10 minutes.
I don't know if I should You know what?
I'll I'll just stay on here for 10
minutes. We'll see how it goes.
Okay. Remember, I'm I'm risking
you know, this is five points. Okay. So,
let's just draw some lines here. So,
from 60
What do we say it was? 63.
53 would be about right here. This would
be 10 points.
50 63
Around here would be This would be one.
This is two. You know, when I say one
and two, what I'm talking about is uh
>> [sighs]
>> R R. And again, you know, my stop.
Just right up here.
So, this trade's been going on for how
long? It's gone it out.
4 5
6 minutes so far.
You know, the other nice thing up here,
I've made a bunch of videos recently
about this as well.
This is bearish value area absorption,
right? And it's coming in to see you got
absorption coming in at this
swing high with the exhaustion.
Okay.
And again, it's just hanging right
around
our entry price.
We're 7 minutes into the trade.
You know, at this point I'm starting to
wonder what's going on.
Why isn't it making a move? The best
trades are going to start moving
quickly.
It's kind of struggling.
This is our low for since we've been in
the trade. Got a higher low here.
Honestly, if it starts coming back up
into this pinkish area, which is the
value area where we had that absorption
earlier,
I wouldn't be surprised to see it go
back in there, but at same time, I
wouldn't want it to go back in there,
especially if I'm short and we're
getting further away from the time that
you got short at.
Okay, so there it trades right back in
there.
>> [sighs and gasps]
>> Yeah, at this point, you know,
like I said, you're 8 minutes into the
trade here
and it's just right around break even.
You just better off, you know,
trying to cover it rather than try to
get fancy and and do anything else.
Okay, cuz again, that's where you're
short from and right now it's just
above, but again, this is my resistance
area anyway.
You know, if if I have resistance marked
you do expect the market to trade back
into resistance at some point. Okay.
But, you know, if you can take a small
loss here, fine. If you can scratch it,
even better.
But again, you know, we're running into
the cash close at this time. So,
you know, take it for what you will.
So, you know, I'll just
hold on to this trade, you know, well,
it's not a trade I would take, but I'm
just on on the line with you while it's
while it's trading.
Um
just making a video to show you the
examples. So, we're right back down at
break even.
This resistance area held, but it's
already 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 minutes into
the trade, and you're back at break
even. That's why I say
just scratch the dang thing if you're
still in the trade. No need to to try
and be a hero because again, I'm looking
for this market to react now, not
go here, go sideways, hang around break
even, then sell off. If it's going to
sell off, it should start selling off.
But I I know I got exhaustion here and
even earlier, exhaustion there,
here. Just looking at the top of these
red bars, you know, they're all got very
thin volumes for the most part.
You know, even though that doesn't
qualify as exhaustion print, this one,
this one, or this one. This one, I know
I've got this one right here.
And I had this one that formed right
here as well.
>> [sighs]
>> But again, it's 10 minutes into the
trade, get out already. You don't need
to stay there. See, it just popped up
back into this area. That's why I said
this was your time to get out. You had
all that time to get out. You had that
full minute and even to into the next
bar to get out. So, anyway, guys, you
know, now it goes up. Would would
stopped you out, right? That's why I
say, you got to have a time
you got to understand
you give
a trade
not only
um
financial
risk, I guess, so to speak, but there's
also a time risk to it, right? If it's
not going to if it doesn't move, doesn't
happen
you got to get out of the trade. Right?
I mean, it's like being in a bad
relationship, right? Bad marriage. You
know, how much time you're going to give
it before you you
you guys separate. And same thing with
with trading. But, this market gave you
plenty of time to get out in here
after it started making a move, and then
you can just sort of see the price is
just struggling to go any lower. That's
your That's your opportunity to get out.
All right, guys. This video went a bit
longer than I was expecting. Um but, you
know, it it it was nice that, you know,
as we're talking, I did get an example
to sort of walk you through. So, thanks
for uh
thanks for sticking around on this
video. It's a little bit extra little
bit longer than my normal ones, but you
can see it still hasn't stopped you out,
but it you got to get out, right? When
the market gives you